So I wanted to talk today about insurance,
uh,
which is another risk management device
that's traditionally separate from a
securities which we
talked about last time,
but the underlying principles
are the same. Um, before I begin,
I wanted to just give some
more thoughts about, uh,
the, uh, the diversification through
securities and that will lead us into,
uh, insurance. Uh,
so let me just review a
preceding lecture briefly,
but that purpose,
what we did,
the core theoretical framework
that we had was the mean variance,
uh, theory, the, which led us to
the capital asset pricing model.
But the basic thing was that we had to,
in order to use the framework,
we had to start by
producing estimates of the
expected returns on each
asset we call those are and
the standard deviation of the return on
each asset and the covariance between
the returns of each pair of assets.
And then once we did that,
we could plug that into the formula
that I gave you last time and get the
standard deviation of the portfolio and
the expected return on the portfolio.
And from then on, if you accept the
analysis and the assumptions that, uh,
are the estimates that underlie it,
we pretty much know how to
construct portfolios. Uh,
but the underlying estimates,
uh,
may not accord with your belief or
your intuitive sense of common sense.
And so the other thing that I mentioned
last time was that there seems to be a
really big difference between the expected
return on the stock market and the
expected return on a short term debt.
Uh,
we found an equity premium,
or actually Jeremy Siegel's book
gave an equity premium of 4% a year.
Uh,
and some people find that hard to believe.
How can it be that one asset does
4% a year better than another?
Some people say, well, if that's the case,
I want to invest in nothing
more than that one asset.
Why should I take something
that, uh, is under performing?
Jeremy Siegel goes on further to say that,
uh,
since the mid 19th century,
we've never had a 30 year period
when stocks underperformed bonds.
So as docs are, uh, really, uh,
if anyone who has a investment
horizon of 30 years, you'd think,
why should I ever hold bonds?
Uh,
so the numbers that Jeremy Siegel
produces seem implausibly high for,
uh, for the stock market. So, ah,
what we call this is the, uh, want
to emphasize that I wrote this again,
I like this again,
the equity
premium puzzle,
that term was actually
coined by economists,
Prescott and Mayra,
but it's now in general use that it just
seems that stocks so much outperform
other other investments. So for Jeremy
Siegel and the latest edition of his book,
the equity premium is 4% a year,
uh,
since 1802. That's almost, no,
that's more than as 106 years. Uh, so, uh,
why would that be?
And how can you believe that?
So one question that
comes up is that maybe
this is for the u s data.
And so some people say, well,
maybe,
you know,
why are we looking at the u s because
the u s is an arguably very successful
country. Uh, and so, uh,
we have potentially a,
a bias in our, uh, scholar selection bias.
If you heck as the country you study one
of the most successful countries in the
world, uh, that doesn't
inform you. Can you see now,
uh, that doesn't inform you very well
about what it is for a random country.
And, or for the u s going forward.
Uh, there's something wrong. Uh,
the U S has been successful in financial
markets and it's being imitated by lots
of countries.
Uh,
financial markets similar to ours
are being set up in many places.
But you wonder, you know, maybe they're
over imitating. Maybe, you know,
maybe we were just lucky or maybe it
was because the u s was, was the, uh,
the, uh, the first, uh,
in some ways to develop some of these
financial institutions are one of the
first. And so, but now when the more
and more countries start doing it,
maybe it won't work so well.
The one way of investigating
this is to, uh, to, uh,
get around the selection bias is
to try to look at all countries.
Let's not just look at the United States.
Let's look at every country of the
world and let's see if they have, uh,
if they have a equity
premium. Okay. So, uh,
but there's a problem with that.
And the problem is that countries that
are less successful don't keep data,
that's a problem. Or are they, were they,
they sometimes they just shut down their
stock markets at some point. Uh, this is,
uh,
this is since 1802.
How many countries do you think have
uninterrupted stock market data? Since 18.
Oh,
two.
What do you think you name another
country that probably has it.
What's that Angela? Then
you got UK, you, uh,
uh, I said, uh, if you go
onto the continent though,
they tended to be interrupted by
World War One and World War II. Uh,
what about Japan? Do they have, do
you think they have uninterrupted,
they have a little bit of a
problem around World War Two and a,
or you can try to bridge
the gap, but, uh, but, uh,
anyway, uh, there are people
who've tried to sort this out. Uh,
and, um, there's one, it's
a book by Dimson Marsh,
uh, and Stanton that, uh,
called triumph of the optimists that
Jeremy Siegel quotes. He has a table in,
in,
in the new fourth edition of his
book and Dimension Dimson Marsh,
uh, and, uh, Stanton look at, uh,
the following countries.
Belgium, Italy, Germany, France,
Spain, Japan, Switzerland,
Ireland, Denmark, Netherlands,
UK, Canada, U, s, South Africa,
Australia, and Sweden. Every one of
them has a positive equity premium,
although the u s is on the high side
of them, or it's not the, not the,
not the best, the country that
has the highest equity premium.
And that's for the whole 20th century.
They couldn't go back to the 1802,
uh, the most successful
country, you, Sweden, uh,
and after that Australia.
So us is not the most
successful stock market, uh,
though it's high and the
high on the list. So, uh,
um,
Jeremy Siegel concludes that there is a,
that the equity, he said, uh, that these,
that this book right Dimson Marsh
Stanton, uh, late puts to bed,
any concerns about selection bias.
Uh,
and he claims that so many countries have
shown an equity premium that we can be
confident. He, this book is really
very strong. And the conclusions,
the title of the book
stocks for the long run,
it's docs always outperform other
investments for the long run.
And he said it's not due to
selection bias, but you know,
I kind of wonder the list of countries
that I just read to you that let them
send marsh and Staunton's studied, exclude
some important countries, doesn't it?
What does it exclude? Well, it doesn't
have India, Russia and China in it.
For example, uh, and I know at
least, uh, Russia and China,
do you know anything about their history?
Do they ever need to stock market
disruptions in the last hundred years?
I think it's kind of obvious.
Uh,
they had a communist revolution
in both places. Right. And so, uh,
Russia and China
are not mentioned a buy
or not studied by Demson.
Washington's not. And why not?
Well, they can't get data.
There wasn't this stock work.
Well,
there actually was the stock market in
Russia before 1918 and in China before
1949. So what, what happened to investors?
If you were a Chinese investor
in Chinese stocks in 1949,
what happened? We know
what happened. It went,
that's that famous minus 100% return,
right? Which dominates everything.
And so, uh, uh,
so I think what would Siegel say?
You know,
he's really saying that this equity
premium is enduring and we should believe
it.
Uh, but, uh, I dunno, I think
good. I think what Jeremy would
say is, well, you're looking,
if you look at Russia and China,
you're looking at political factors and
I'm only looking at politically stable
countries. And so this whole
thing is irrelevant really.
We're not going to have a communist
revolution in any of these advanced
countries now.
And so Jeremy would say,
forget that.
It looks pretty sound that
we have an equity premium
until we can trust that, uh,
well he's a good friend of mine, but I
think he may be overstating a little bit.
We have, we'd have some disagreements. Um,
the thing that comes to my mind is that
I wanted to say before concluding this
review of the last lecture,
uh,
that is that the stock market is
inherently political in any country.
That politics have tremendous,
a tremendous effect on the
values in the stock market.
Uh,
and that's because of even if the
government doesn't nationalize the stock
market or confiscate assets,
they tax them. Right. And do you know,
we have in the U s we
have a corporate profits
text?
Well, it's not just in the
u s uh, essentially every,
I don't if there's any exception,
there may not be an exception,
but essentially every country
has a corporate profits tax.
And then we also have
personal
income tax.
Okay.
So the corporate profits tax goes after
the profits that corporations make the
personal, it's taken from corporations
before they pay out their dividends.
The personal income tax is
levied on individuals and, uh,
these individuals have to pay it.
But that the personal
income tax is not simple.
It's not just a flat rate on your income.
It depends on the type of income.
So dividend income or capital income.
And the stock market is taxed differently.
The interesting thing is,
is that through time,
as political winds change,
these taxes have changed.
Uh, and they've gone up through some very
high levels in the past in the United
States and other countries. I'm
going to give some, uh, US tax rate.
Um,
the personal tax on dividends,
of course, it depends also on
your tax bracket and your income.
I'm going to talk about the highest tax
bracket in the u s it went over 90% in
World War II and,
and the succeeding years.
So the government was taking 90%
of your dividend income, right?
What does it today,
do you know what anyone know?
What's the tax rate on dividends today?
Uh,
it might be zero for, yeah, for
some people, but it's actually,
it is a, the standard rate for
people who have not negligent,
not negligible income is 15%.
So it's gone down from over 90% to 15%.
Why did it do that?
Well,
it's some kind of political change and uh,
the, uh, corporate, uh, okay.
And incidentally at the
beginning of the 20th century,
you were right who said
zero. We didn't, uh,
we didn't even have a income tax
until 1913 when the Supreme Court, uh,
allowed it.
So it was zero.
Then it went up to 90% are
actually is 94% of the peak.
It came down to 15%. Okay. That's a
pretty big hit on the stock market. So,
you know,
it wasn't just China that took the
stock market when we were taking 90% of
dividends, that was 90% of the stock
market was being taken by the government.
But that's not all because we were
also taxing the corporations. Uh,
and in the early postwar period,
the corporate,
now I'm going to talk,
there is a distinction between the rate
that they charge and the actual amount
that they take. Uh, uh,
most advanced countries of the world today
have a corporate profits tax rate for
large corporations have about a third.
So they typically,
a typical advanced country
takes a third of the profits.
The government takes a
third of the profits,
but that's not the actual
amount that they pay.
Because it tax law is so complicated
and there's so many loopholes.
So what I looked at,
and I have this on the website,
I have a chart showing corporate profits
taxes paid as a fraction of corporate
profits for the United States since 1929.
Uh,
and that had moved around a lot,
but it got almost up to 60% in the,
in the post World War II period.
And now it's down to less than a third.
Uh,
why is it that is because they're
changing enforcement of the taxes and the
changing of marks of loopholes.
So, uh, most countries, uh,
they have a tax rate of about a third,
but corporations are paying less than
a third of their profits detective.
So if we want to look going
forward at the equity premium,
we have to know how much, uh, what,
what's the politics and what's the
government going to do in the future?
And they've moved these
tax rates around a lot.
So I think that it's very hard to be
sure that we know going forward what are
sigma and, uh, the, the expected return,
the standard deviation of returns.
And the covariance of returns are really,
so we have a nice theoretical framework,
but the application of the framework
to the real data is hard and it ends up
politics underneath it all. And
that's, uh, that's just the real world.
I want to say one more thing
about, uh, about the, uh,
uh, diversification in a mutual fund. Uh,
ideally mutual funds are calculating
our and sigma and sigma one two,
and plugging in and finding what the
optimal portfolio that you should hold is,
and then offering that to you in
their mutual fund. That, uh, in,
in Prac, it's firms that do
that are in practice. However,
the minority and most mutual funds
have some gimmick or some special,
uh, they claimed to be beating the
market, not forming the optimal portfolio.
And I also have up on the website,
uh,
some questions that I
asked investors about, uh,
about, uh, what they
think about picking stock.
Picking stocks means trying to find a
stock that's going to do really well. Uh,
and so, uh, what I found,
the question I asked is,
um,
do you agree or say which of the following
is a correct answer to this statement?
Trying to time the market to get out
before it goes down and in before it goes
up. Is a smart thing to do, or B,
not a smart thing to do.
Most people think that it's not a smart
thing to do to try to time the market.
Only 11% said yes to that.
But then I ask another question.
Do you think, uh, trying to pick
mutual funds, uh, trying to,
to find a mutual fund that
will beat the market, uh,
is a smart thing to do or not a smart
thing to do the most people think it's a
smart thing to do.
So what I think the mutual fund industry
has turned into largely is a stock
picking industry,
not a portfolio diversification industry.
Uh, and so what most people are doing
when they go into a mutual fund is they're
trying to find smart people
who will beat market,
will pick those stocks that will do well.
Uh,
but the Mutual Fund theory that
we gave last time said, no,
the mutual fund is just supposed to
be diversifying for you. In fact,
the truth is somewhere in between.
Most mutual funds are providing some
diversification service and they're also
trying to, uh, they're also trying to
beat the market. Finally, I
just wanted to say that I,
I've been talking mainly about
the, uh, about the u s but, uh,
mutual funds have been growing
in importance around the world.
Uh, and, uh, there was a
recent paper by, um, uh,
Havana surveys,
I'm sorry,
Urana
surveys
and too far now that looked
at when it is that explains,
uh, which, uh, countries have
had rapidly growing mutual
fund industries. And they
found, not surprisingly,
that it tends to,
mutual funds have been growing more
rapidly in countries that have stronger
securities laws and institutions,
especially laws that protect
individual shareholders rights. Also,
a mutual funds had been growing more
in countries that have higher level of
education and higher level of wealth.
Uh,
and they also grow more in countries
that have institutional structures that
encourage, uh, that encourage, uh,
investing in mutual funds
such as pension plans. Uh,
but I think it's a trend around the world
that we're going to see more and more
mutual funds. Uh, and I
think it's a good thing.
I think they will help us
to diversify our risks.
Uh,
so anywhere I wanted them to move on to
the topic of today's lecture, which is,
uh, insurance and, uh,
the insurance is the other side
of the risk management, uh, that,
uh,
institutions that we have insurance
evolved separately from securities.
It's long been a different industry,
but the principles are the same.
And the principles of Insurance,
the fund,
the fundamental powerhouse is the
principle of risk pooling and,
uh, insurance, just like mutual funds
or providing risk pooling for you.
Okay.
So risk pooling means they put a lot of
people in independent or low correlated
risk into a pore and reduce the
risk for the whole pool. Uh,
they have to contend with
something called moral hazard,
which is the risk that people will be
affected by the fact that they're insured
and then do something bad.
The classic moral hazard
problem is the problem that, uh,
you would give fire insurance on her
house and so someone burns down the house
in order to collect the insurance.
Um,
and they also have to
deal with selection bias.
Uh,
what this means it in the insurance
context is that if you offer insurance
policies, you will tend to attract
people who are higher risk.
All right?
So if you offer life insurance,
you have life tables which give you
probabilities of dying at various ages,
but that's for the general population.
All the sick people will come to you to
buy life insurance and they will, uh,
turn out to have a higher death
rate than the population at large.
So these are the problems of
insurance that we have to deal with.
Um,
I just wanted to review
the mathematics of this.
This is actually just in part I just to
review of what we talked about in the
second lecture. But, uh,
in the ideal world,
if you have independent risks,
uh, under the independence assumption, the
probability distribution
for the number of, uh,
contract,
uh,
insurance contracts that you will
have to pay on follows the binomial
distribution.
So x is the number of accidents that
say this is some accident insurance.
Okay.
Oops.
Uh, the, the, uh,
the probability of having an
n is the number of policies
that you're writing and if you're going
to have p is the probability of an
accident.
Okay?
Then the binomial distribution,
uh,
gives you the probability of having
x accidents out of your end policies.
And, uh, we had that before. That is, uh,
it is, um, p two,
the x one minus one minus x
power,
uh,
times and all over
x factorial times and x factorial.
And so that is the binomial distribution
and it allows you to calculate the,
the probability of any
number of accidents. Uh, the,
the mean, uh, proportion
as the mean of x over n,
which is a,
is equal to p. So, uh,
am I writing big enough?
I can see the, uh, uh,
if x is the number of accidents,
the mean number of accidents divided by
your number of policies is given just by
the probability,
but the standard deviation of x over n
is equal to the square root of p
times one minus p all over again.
And so that is the should get these,
uh,
so that is the,
that gives us a mean and standard
deviation of the proportion.
So to actually apply this,
it helps to go to something called the
normal approximation cause the binomial.
Uh, so, uh,
because it's kind of difficult to compute,
this formula is an easier
formula and you assume that,
uh,
the binomial distribution is really
a normal distribution with a mean of,
let's say the proportion
of accidents x over,
around and follows a normal distribution
with mean p and standard deviation
given by this.
Uh,
and that's all, that's the, uh,
the whole theory that I have here.
It's simple. Um, so maybe I should
make a bigger, well, let me do it here.
I can fit it in here.
I think
I'm going to draw an example. I've got
a plot it out and it's on the website,
but it's a very simple example where
I have the case where p equals 0.2.
Okay,
so the probability of an accident is 20%.
This is a significantly high probability
of accident. Can you see down,
you can see all of this right from zero.
Let's do this from zero to 0.4.
Uh, if, uh, if you wrote only one policy,
what's the probability
distribution of x over n? Well,
it has two possible values.
It could be the one person doesn't have
the accident or does have the accident.
So if any equals one,
uh, we have, uh,
an 80% chance this would be 80% of,
of, uh, of no accident. Uh, and uh,
actually this makes this one not 0.4 then
a 20% chance of one of x over n equals
one. Okay? So I'm plodding, uh,
this is the probability
of various values of x,
ovarian, if any equals one x over
and can take on only two values,
zero or one. And it takes on the
value one with a probability of 20%.
And the value of zero with a probability
of 80% I didn't use the normal
approximation there. I just, that's
obvious, right? I use the binomial itself,
but let's go to the case
ware and as a hundred then,
uh,
see how should I,
maybe I'll leave that up. You can see
this, okay, these diagrams on growing,
if Annie was a hundred,
now I'm going to label this access
differently and now I'm going to show the
normal bell shaped curve.
And I'm going to do this from zero to 0.4.
Maybe I do have to make this be,
can you see this all right back there?
Okay,
so zero to 0.4.
Uh,
and so 0.2 is here in the middle.
That's 0.2, uh, for any equals.
Now I'm going to do any
equals a hundred. Okay. Uh,
what is the mean?
But the mean is always point to no
matter how many policies you write.
So it's going to be,
we're going to have a normal
distribution centered on point to
this point to is not very readable here.
Um,
I have to crunch down and to do it.
Okay. So, uh,
and what does the standard deviation is
the square root of 0.2 times 0.8 over a
hundred. So that's a 0.16, uh,
uh,
over a hundred.
So the standard deviation is 0.04.
Uh,
so what does the curve look like?
it's a bell shaped curve
that looks about like that.
I didn't draw that very well.
We try it again. I should do,
I'll do a nice bell shaped curves,
but uh,
it's harder than it
looks standing up here.
Okay. So that's your bell shape
curve. So with a hundred policies,
uh,
they can't really count that accurately
on having 20% of the policies pay.
There's still substantial
insurance risk because the,
it could easily be only 15% or
it could be 25% of the policies,
uh,
that ended up paying.
So the insurance company with a hundred
policies would have still substantial
risk. It's much better. The, the,
the uncertainty about x over n is much
lower for the case n equals a hundred
than it was for the case. N
Equals one. But it's still there.
Now I want to draw,
what if we write 10,000 policies?
Okay?
Uh,
and so what is the probability
distribution for x over N in that case?
But you can see you're going to
be dividing that by 100 here,
but by a hundred times a hundred.
So it's going to reduce
this from 0.04 2.04.
Okay.
And so the normal,
the bell shaped curve in that case for
the x over n is going to look something
like this. Well, I've got a plotted
here. It's even more steeply than that.
That's a bell shape curve,
but it's Senate exactly on point
to exactly a number of policies.
It doesn't affect the mean,
but it affects this Dan deviation.
So it becomes very collapsed. And this
is the basic core idea of insurance.
You have to be a big company to do it.
And if you have a big company,
you've exhausted the, uh, the risk of
a almost never goes away completely.
Uh, and so if we did a,
uh, we could go another,
another two decimal. If we did
a million Chi now, uh, yeah,
a million, uh, policies, then we
would, this would almost be just, uh,
a spike here at, uh, at that point.
But that's the concept of
insurance. Um, but, uh, the idea,
uh, uh, really took root, the idea,
the intuitive idea that as you
write a large number of policies,
the fraction that are,
that will result in accidents becomes
closer and closer to the probability of
one accident.
That's an idea that it struck,
struck people intuitively
at various times in history,
but they didn't know how to, um, how to
do these calculations. So, uh,
historians of probability have noted
that this basic idea is actually in
Aristotle, the ancient Greek
philosopher or scientist,
and I'm going to quote Aristotle
from his book, Decarlo,
uh, it, and he says to, uh,
he's talking very generally
here, but I think it's this,
he's really talking about this.
He says,
to succeed in many things or
many times is quote difficult.
For instance,
to repeat the same throw of dice a
10,000 times would be impossible.
Whereas to make it once or twice,
it's comparatively easy.
That's Aristotle talking.
It's exactly this theory,
but he doesn't have the word probability,
which hadn't been invented yet.
So he's using intuitive,
he says, difficult or easy.
So he says it's difficult,
meaning the probability is very low
or easy. It probability is high.
He had the idea, but he didn't
have the math. Uh, so that,
I think that may be the first a known
statement of the binomial distribution.
Well, it doesn't get very precise,
but it has the intuitive concept.
The idea of using this theory
for insurance. Uh, it's,
uh, the earliest known
statement of it is a, uh,
it was in an anonymous letter
written in 1609 to account Oldenburg.
But that's not the person who said it.
That was the person who received
the letter. Uh, anyway, uh,
the person wrote,
he was talking about fires and it was
proposing that people should pay 1% of the
value of the home every year into a
fund and then the fund would be used to
replace the home if it burned down and
coating this anonymous person writing in
1609.
Uh,
there is no doubt that it would be fully
proved if a calculation we're made of
the number of houses consumed by fire
within a certain space in the course of 30
years,
that the loss would not amount by a
good deal to the some that would be
collected in that time.
So it's interesting that this
person uses the word calculation.
This person has the idea,
this is the 1600 was the year when
probability theory was invented.
So someone had the idea of going
beyond the intuitive notion that, uh,
Aristotle have mentioned and moving
to something that is calculable.
And that's when the insurance
industry, it was really born. So,
uh, it's, so insurance relies
on this theory of risk pooling,
but it has to make it work. Uh, and I,
I stressed in the third lecture that,
uh,
like any insurance,
like any other risk management
device is an invention. And that, uh,
uh,
every risk management device relies
on a design and the design is,
uh,
is usually complex and has
it all has to work together.
In order for a design to work well,
we have to have every component there.
If one component is missing,
we may have a failure.
All of these components have to be
compatible with each other and it has to
work. Uh, in a, um,
I work according to a plan which
ultimately is informed by this theory.
So insurance as an invention
has to have what, what, uh,
things,
uh,
it has to have a contract design.
It, that would be a, uh, document, uh,
which is a contract between the
insured and the insurance company.
It specifies what does it specify?
It specifies what risks
are covered, uh, and uh,
exclusions.
Some risks are not covered.
Uh,
and those exclusions are carefully
designed in regard of moral hazard and
selection bias.
Um, there, there has to
be the mathematical model,
which I just presented, but it
may be more complicated. Um,
there has to be a form for the company.
Uh,
there could be a corporate
form that there's the,
the insurance company
could be a corporation and,
uh,
or it could be either a
nonprofit corporation or a
for profit corporation owned
by shareholders or the insurance company
could be a mutual insurance company,
in which case the insurance
company is owned by the insured.
Um,
and then you need as well,
you need a government regulation
because,
uh,
the insurance companies don't
seem to exist without it.
There has to be regulators that are
at least verifying that the insurance
company is doing what it it,
it says it's going to do.
And so,
uh,
one thing that the government
has to do is assure that, uh,
reserves requirements are met.
The company has to have enough money
on hand to pay out, uh, in the,
in the case of default.
So,
uh,
okay.
One way of classifying,
uh,
insurance companies is that they,
um,
can exist as either a multiline
insurance companies
or mono line
insurance companies.
A multiline insurance company insures
many different kinds of things,
uh, and, uh, doesn't
confine itself to one thing.
So if a company were just a,
a fire insurance company,
it would be a mono line
insurance company. Uh, but,
but then they're essentially more risky
and more regulators have to watch them
more because they're,
they're standing a higher probability
amount of line of some major disaster.
Uh, and, uh,
in contrast to a multiline
kind of ensures, uh, it, uh,
itself.
Uh,
so we hear a lot about mono-line insurance
companies in the newspapers today.
I don't know if you're reading
about the subprime crisis, but, uh,
we are living in a time at this
moment of a financial crisis,
uh, called the subprime crisis. And, uh,
that naturally hits mono-line insurance
companies more than multiline insurance
companies because they are more
specialized and more vulnerable.
Uh, I'll come back to this
distinction in a minute,
but I wanted to talk
about a certain kinds of,
uh, of, uh, uh, uh,
mono line insurance
companies that, uh, uh,
the biggest, uh, well, one
category is property and casualty
insurance company or PNC.
He's aren't insurance companies
that insure the value of
a home or a business or
an automobile.
Uh,
and another kind of monolines insurances,
health insurance company that merely
ensures people against health costs.
And another important
category is life insurance.
Uh, so, uh, life insurance is,
uh, w what it ensures is, uh,
a beneficiary against the
death of an insured. Uh,
and the classic example of the
most important example is families.
Uh,
the,
you would buy life insurance on
both the husband and the wife.
Okay. You might have, might do
different amount and it's done right.
Families with young children to protect
them against the economic cost of the
death of one of their parents.
Uh,
and you need insurance on both parents
because both parents are contributing,
uh, to the, uh, success
of the children. So,
um, these are big industries. Uh, the, uh,
total assets of a property and
casualty in 2007 and the United States,
uh,
and these are assets,
property and casualty, uh, was
one point $4 trillion.
Uh,
and life insurance was
four point $9 trillion.
So, uh, I don't actually did, I don't have
to, somehow I missed getting the health,
but that would be another big, uh,
insurance. So this is a, these are huge,
hugely important institutions,
uh, in our, uh, in our, um,
in our society. So, uh,
what are, what does proper,
let me go to property and
casualty. Um, what do they insure?
Uh,
actually the most important that
thing that they insure is automobiles.
Uh,
the total premiums collected on
automobiles is about, is much bigger.
I like five times bigger than the
premiums they collect on homeowners.
Automobile Insurance is
collision insurance. Okay.
Homeowner's insurance is used to be
called fire insurance, but now they've,
they've extended it to include
so many other risks. Uh,
it depends on the particular policy,
what it includes.
It might include risks as well of
personal liability if someone injures
themselves on your property or
risks of storms of hurricanes,
earthquakes, everything else. So
we call it homeowners insurance,
but actually the automobile
insurance is more important.
And then the homeowners insurance, even
the homes are so much more valuable. Uh,
because I think that's because cars move
and they drive around and they bumped
into each other, cut homes,
just stay where they are.
And so we have far fewer accidents so
they don't have to charge is high premium,
uh, for, uh, for, uh,
for the, uh, insurance. So, uh,
these insurance contracts have
come across gradually through time.
Uh, as we developed the theory, uh,
and I talk about the growth of insurance
and about some of the components of it.
Uh,
uh,
real insurance industry, as I mentioned
before, began in the 16 hundreds,
uh,
with the invention of theory and with
the invention of a life tables for an
invention of actuarial science.
But it grew slowly.
And I think the reason that it grew
slowly was that insurance is a very
sophisticated concept. Uh,
in order to explain it,
I had to write down in the
binomial distribution and, uh,
I have to explain it properly. For most
people, that's a difficult concept.
Uh, and so, uh, I think I may have
mentioned some of this before,
but let me give this history,
uh, in, uh, insurance,
it was invented in the 16 hundreds,
but it did not for the, for eight fast.
They proliferate,
proliferated only very slowly.
And some of the,
uh,
important figures is there had
to be certain inventions, uh,
to make it work. Uh, again,
I'm repeating a theme that isn't my book,
New Financial Order,
that financial innovation and
insurance innovation is a succession of
inventions.
And each invention propels
the idea more forward.
So it's like,
uh,
we have laws of thermodynamics
that underlie the use of engines.
Uh, and, but you know,
you can't just go from the laws of
thermodynamics to an automobile.
There's a million steps along the way.
And if you look at the history of engines,
there are discreet advances.
And when people were able to apply the
theory more and more, well, in insurance,
there's a similar list of inventions.
So, uh, Morris, Robert Robinson,
uh, was head of mutual life, um,
of New York
and the 1840s.
Uh, and he, uh,
got the idea of highly paid
life insurance salespeople.
Uh, the idea was that, uh,
it's difficult to sell people on insurance
back in the 1840 [inaudible] life
insurance was very important because
the average expectancy of life was only
something like 45 years. And so that
meant parents were dying left and right.
What would be the probability that a
married couple would live both of them to
the, uh, to the, uh, time
when their children are grown?
Uh, well it was fairly low, right?
If the average age at death was
something like 45, uh, you know,
maybe a 50, 50 chance of,
of high a risk, uh, of,
of one of the parents dying.
So you should think that people would
really want life insurance, but they,
uh, but they were not buying it.
And why was it? Well, first of all,
they were dying in such numbers.
P was so high that it was expensive.
They have to pay that premium
has to cover the costs.
And so it was tough to get
someone to buy life insurance
even though they really needed it. It
was such a idea for them. Uh, but, uh,
it's partly because there's a
psychological resistance to it, you know,
this is still very much alive today.
I was standing at the World Economic
Forum at one of our lunch things and a
young woman approached me from Swiss re,
uh, which is a Swiss reinsurance company.
And she said she wanted my ideas on
how to sell crop insurance and Africa.
She said, we have it now at Swiss re. Uh,
and of course the World Bank sponsors
a crop insurance for farmers. So,
and there are some very poor areas in
Africa where farmers really run the risk
if their crop fails, uh, it could
be really bad. Uh, you know,
they would be approaching starvation.
So wouldn't you think that farmers would
want to buy crop insurance from this
Swiss company?
It looks like a good idea to me,
but she says we're having a
lot of trouble selling it. Uh,
and uh,
he said,
if you talk to the farmers
in these rural areas,
what do you think they say when you offer?
They say, I can't afford the insurance.
Well, they're not
thinking, right. You know,
the whole idea of insurance is that you
take from your good years and you move
it into your bad year so that you
make it through all your years.
And so you're having
a good year this year.
Maybe it looks that way now and
you think you can't afford it,
but just think how bad it will be. If
it's a bad year, then you really won't.
You won't feel afford to
stay alive. Uh, and so, uh,
but she says they didn't,
some of them respond,
but a great majority of them don't.
And I think it's because
of a psychological aversion
to people have to thinking
about insurance.
It's just unpleasant.
And Life Insurance is actually an
insurance against one of you dying.
It's a very unpleasant topic. So if
someone comes to your home and says, I'm,
I would like to send a sell you life
insurance. You know, you think, you know,
some other day,
I don't want to talk today
about the probability of
one of us dying. Uh, and so,
uh, it was a tough sell. So
Morris Robinson, however,
realized that some people are very
talented salespeople and they're probably
talented at other things as well.
So it may sound like a small, uh,
a small improvement,
but he just had very highly
paid insurance sales,
uh, and they were paid as long
as people kept their policy.
And so that motivated insurance salesman
to form long term relationships with
the families and he was insuring and to
keep them from canceling their policies.
So he got talented,
respected members of the community who
people admired to become life insurance
salesman and he had to pay them enough
so that they would stick with the job.
And then it finally worked.
It may seem crazy,
but it may seem like a modest
innovation, but it actually, uh, was,
uh,
it was an important innovation.
So I don't know how you think
of life insurance salespeople,
but they have been pillars of the
community. There are people that you,
the community trusts that people are
willing to let into their home and discuss
things like death.
Uh,
and that was an innovation
that came in then.
Then the other innovation was Henry.
Hi. Uh, and he was at,
uh,
another insurance company,
equitable life.
MMM.
Uh,
and that was in the late 18 hundreds.
Uh, and what he invented was a
insurance policy that had a cash value.
And that's another, uh, it's a
cash value on the insurance policy.
That is that the insurance
policy doesn't just
insure you against death. It also
builds value over the years. Uh,
and this invention was very important
because it stopped people from canceling.
The big problem with life insurance had
his people would buy it and they'd pay
for several years. Uh, and then
eventually they would think, well,
we didn't die. We were losing all this
money. Let's just cancel the insurance.
And it especially happens the way life
is and real families is, you know,
you start getting accustomed to a certain
style of life and you start spending
more and more money and
then it comes upon it.
There comes a time when you have
a little crunch and you know,
you're a little short on
money and so you're casting,
you're out for some way to
come up with some money.
And so canceling your life
insurance was a good idea. Uh,
but, uh, uh,
the turns out that if you make them
forfeit their cash value on canceling,
then they won't cancel. And so,
um, that both of these were ideas,
uh, that, uh, were copied
all over the world.
That's the way inventions are.
Uh,
and so a lot of insurance policies
today have cash values. Uh,
the third thing I was going to report,
uh,
was a sociologist Viviana Zelizer,
wrote a book about life insurance
salesmen sales in the night in the 19th
century. And she found that, uh,
there was a lot of resistance to purchase
of life insurance in the 19th century.
Uh,
and she tried to study it and try to
figure out how it was that life insurance
became more and more important
over that century. Uh,
and one of her conclusions without life
insurance seem to be opposed quite a bit
by women, uh, 19th century women.
Uh,
and why didn't they like it?
You would think that any rational,
a woman in the 19th century would reflect
on the fact that there's a significant
probability that her husband will die of
something while you still have children.
And why wouldn't they want a,
well,
what she found is that
life insurance salespeople,
we're going to families and trying to
sell them on life insurance by explaining
the concept. And they would
say something like, I did.
Maybe they didn't write down
the binomial distribution,
but they explained the idea
of insurance. Uh, and uh,
it didn't sound right to the typical 19th
century American woman or I suppose it
wasn't just America.
It was a worldwide problem.
And the reaction that salespeople would
get from women was, you know, this, this,
you're giving me some probabilities or
something. And you're asking me too.
It sounds like you're asking me to play
in some gambling thing where I win.
If my husband dies, it doesn't,
it doesn't sound right to me.
Uh, I think, uh, in fact a lot
of women would say something.
I put my faith in God,
and I think I might bring down God's
wrath if I did such a thing as to bet that
my husband is going to die.
Uh, and so she would, uh,
refuse to take part in it.
It doesn't sound right to her.
I'll trust in prayer and other things.
Uh,
so it didn't work and you
couldn't sell them on.
So what Xcel is a reported is that some
life insurance companies surmounted this
problem by changing the pitch,
by telling their salespeople,
don't try to explain probability
theory to these people, uh,
but you have to do is come
across differently. And so the,
the thing that she said they started doing
is to pretend that in a way that they
were missionaries with a Gospel
and the Gospel is insurance.
Uh, and they would tell
these women, uh, you know,
if you buy life insurance on your husband,
then should anything happen,
your husband can love and protect
you from beyond the grave. Uh,
and uh, that sounds
good. So, uh, it worked.
And these little things you, you may,
they may seem like little things,
but they are technological advances.
People in a profession over the
years learn more and more how to, um,
how to,
uh,
how to manage the public's expectations
and get them to actually purchase
insurance. So, uh,
I wanted to talk about government
regulation of insurance because, uh,
I said that was an important
aspect of insurance. Uh,
and what the regulators
do. Many things, uh,
but insurance regulators, uh, most of our,
our concern with capital adequacy, so, uh,
so insurance,
now insurance is in the United States,
is regulated not by the federal government
but by insurance regulators in each
of the 50 states.
So it's very hard to summarize insurance
regulation in the United States.
Why is it regulated separately
by the 50 states? Uh,
that's because it started out that
way when the federal government wasn't
involved in those sorts of things. But
somehow we never had the, uh, uh, in fact,
it's talked about, we should maybe we'll
see it in the next 10 or 20 years. Uh,
there's talked about that there should
be a federal government regulation of
insurance, but it's actually state
regulators and it makes it hard.
This is a handicap to the
US insurance industry.
Other countries have it centralized, but
in the U S it's split up over 50 states,
it was very hard to start an insurance
company because you've got to meet the
requirements of all 50 regulators.
But the most important thing that
these do is they specify what reserves
insurance companies have
to hold. Okay. And so,
uh, they, in other words,
the insurance company doesn't trust
the insurance companies to do the
calculations like I just showed
with the binomial theorem.
They want to make sure that there's a
significantly high probability it since
sufficiently high probability
that even if they get a bad draw,
and there's a lot of policies
that require paying out,
that these reserves will satisfy.
Uh,
so an insurance company must hold
the reserves, it can hold more.
Uh, and that's called a
statutory surplus. So, uh,
the reserves are an accounting entry. It's
how much they are required to hold. Uh,
but the companies will hold
more than that. Uh, if, uh,
typically in order to protect themselves
more than is required and their policy
holders more than is required
by the regulators. So,
uh, occasionally you get
into problems, uh, with uh,
with the reserves. And, um, uh,
before I get to that, let me just
say, uh, uh, I want to just mention,
mentioned a few types of insurance
that are important. So, uh,
let's talk about life insurance
and we're talking about kinds of
policies that are around today.
The simplest form of life insurance.
It's called term insurance.
Okay.
And this is insurance that you pay each
year for insurance in that year and it
does not build a cash value.
So this is the symbol of me.
I can buy insurance for myself this year,
uh,
and I can stop and if I,
there's no nothing her,
uh,
next year I would just
have to pay it again. Um,
whole life is more complicated
because it builds a,
a cash value according to a schedule.
Uh,
and uh,
there is both a non participating and
participating with non participating what
was participating.
You in a,
you are participating in the portfolio
outcome that the insurance company is
experiencing and so you have some
uncertainty about your cash value.
Um, there's something
called variable life, uh,
which refers to a life insurance policy
where the policy holder can shift.
You can make decisions about the
investment of the money in the whole life
policy. And so it's not just taking
what's given by the insurance company.
There's something called universal life.
These are all explained
in full Bozi at uh, uh,
that's a,
it's a whole life policy that gives
the policyholder flexibility over the
insurance premiums.
You can pay more into the cash value in
one year and less than another year as
long as you keep paying a
a, a minimum amount. Um,
and uh,
it was also survivorship policies,
uh, that will pay, uh, uh,
for example, uh, the second to die.
There'll be a policy if a
husband and wife get it and uh,
it pays out when the second of them dies.
Or also about regulation.
I want to dimension n a I see very
important institution that stands for
National Association of
Insurance Commissioners. Uh,
and this is something
that's very important in the
United States because as I
mentioned,
uh,
insurance regulation is
divided up over the 50 states.
And the problem that that creates is a,
that it's a nightmare for
insurance companies because
every different state has
different laws. Uh,
recognizing this problem,
the insurance commissioners in the
various dates have decided to form an
organization that's the NAI seat
and they hold regular conferences.
Uh, and at these conferences they, uh,
decide on a recommended or uniform
like insurance regulation policy,
uh, and it acts a little bit like
a congress and they make laws,
but the laws are not binding on anyone.
They just suggested laws or regulations.
Uh, and so it's an effort to
try to get the complex, uh,
uh, complexity of different
regulators uniform. So as I say,
when they nai see decides
on some regulation,
it's only a recommendation to the
separate state regulatory commissions.
Uh,
but of course it has a lot of force
because all 50 states have met.
The commissioner has a 50 states
I've met and hashed it out. Uh,
so most states would essentially
adopt with the NAI c says, uh,
otherwise, you know, they're
not going to figure it all out.
They can't claim the beat. It would
be rational to do that. Right?
You wouldn't think that we would rethink
all of these things ourselves and then
have a different in our state.
So the NAI C is kind of a quasi
regulatory body or is it quasi government?
It's not government,
uh,
because it has no authority and yet it
acts almost like a parliament where these
people get together and decide on things
and they end up as a force of law.
Uh, so, uh,
another important, uh, there's some
milestones in insurance that, um,
I wanted to mention.
Um,
and then I'm going to come back to finally
concluding with problems that we see.
Uh, and of course the
problems are not damning.
There are problems that reflect the
progress yet needed to be made and
insurance. But, um, I just
wanted to mention the, uh,
the um,
uh,
the itch
lily,
um,
financial modernization act
of 1999.
And what this did is it allowed
banks to offer insurance or to,
uh, ally and join in merge
with insurance companies.
Before that did I said before, insurance
is really the same thing as security.
So both based on risk
management and pooling of risk
diversification or pooling.
I really the same thing,
but we had a separate set of institute
and people never thought of insurance as
the same as a bank. Uh, but since
this is relatively recently,
that's only nine years
ago, um, at this time.
So it means then that we are now seeing a,
uh,
expansion of our banking
system in the u s to become,
uh, uh, insurance related. It's
different in other countries.
In Europe they've had a universal banking
which allowed banks to offer insurance
for a much longer time.
But in the U S it's a kind of a recent,
a recent innovation.
So I wanted to conclude with problems,
which may sound kind of,
but, uh, this is, uh,
I don't shrink from negative is
it's not really negative isn't it?
It's talking about what,
what should be done.
So I wanted to come back to,
I told you that Marta line
was in the news a lot lately.
And so why don't we talking about when it,
uh,
I don't know how much you read about that.
Okay.
Uh,
right now we are going through a major
financial crisis which started in the u s
but has spread over the world
and this is called the, uh,
the subprime crisis.
Yeah.
Subprime refers to mortgages, which
is not the subject of today's lecture,
but a sub prime mortgage is a mortgage
issued to a borrower who is not
considered a crime.
That's not a good risk.
Borrowers that are thought by the
various models to be likely to fail,
to pay on their mortgage and
to have to be foreclosed low,
often low income. But also there are
people with poor credit histories.
So, uh, the crisis that we're in now,
and this is very important you
where you're living through it. Uh,
and we'll see how it pans out.
Uh,
the subprime crisis is happening today
because home prices are falling and with
falling home prices more
subprime borrowers are re are,
are failing to pay their mortgage and
default rates are shooting up and a
valuation of securitized subprime
mortgages have crashed. Uh,
and it's throwing turmoil all over
the [inaudible] all over the financial
community. Uh, it's, we're, we're
seeing what they call systemic effects.
Uh,
that's a very general term that goes
beyond insurance. By systemic effects,
I mean something that affects
the whole financial system.
Uh, and when you do these calculations,
which I just did for insurance,
I was talking about insurance companies,
assuming that risks are independent,
everything's independent, we've got
it all figured out. Uh, underlying at,
there were other things besides just
the calculation of their accident rates
that I had a certain assumptions built in.
Uh,
and the failure of the assumptions in
many different industries can create
systemic effects.
So what happened?
I want to talk about a particular line
of Mano Line insurers that you may never
have even heard of because they
don't deal with the general public.
And these are municipal bonds
insurance.
Okay. These are private
companies, insurance companies,
their motto line,
because they look only at a certain
class of risk and not all risks that the
insurer they deal with principally with
state and local governments who are
issuing bonds to raise money for their
activities like new haven, for
example. Uh, or any other, uh,
any state or local government,
we refer to the bonds that they
issue as municipal bonds. Now,
the problem is that if you invest in
bonds from some state or local government,
they might not pay you back.
They can just go bankrupt.
The cities going bankrupt
and they just can't pay. Uh,
and so you as a, as a
buyer of these bonds, uh,
feel reluctant to invest in them.
Okay?
So in order to make their guns salable
to the general public city and state
governments go,
or any region,
a local governments go to the
municipal bond insurer companies,
uh,
and
they have names.
Big Ones are Mbia Ambac,
uh, F G I see. That's not FDA. I see.
It's not the Federal Deposit
Insurance Corporation.
It's f GIC and there are others as well.
Okay.
And so what these do is
they ensure the bond.
They ensure the investor against the
municipality failing to pay on the bond.
All right?
And so lots of investors won't buy a
municipal bond unless it's insured.
Uh, okay. So now I'm talking about
systemic effects in the home.
So these insurance companies have
reserves on hand and they invest these
reserves in something. So what
are they invest in then? Well,
one of the things they've been investing
in a man, uh, is sub mortgages. You know,
I can see what I'm talking
about. Systemic effect. So, uh,
the housing sector in the United States,
you might say is completely different
from municipal bond insurers.
But when the housing
sector starts going down,
people start defaulting
on their mortgages. Uh,
then the value of the subprime
loans that the mortgage,
municipal bond insurers own
starts to go down. Okay.
Now these guys have never failed
to live up to their guarantees.
They're doing just fine.
But people are noticing that
their portfolios are going down.
And so their surplus,
uh,
statutory surplus is going down. And, uh,
and so we're starting to
worry about these companies.
And so notably it was January 18,
a rating agency, Fitch lowered
handbag
from AAA rated to Aa
rated. Okay. That was a big news story
or you might not have caught it right?
But it was a big news story for the
field work in municipal government.
You Thought, oh, this is bad
news. If this is the only,
if only one rating agency
does that. Okay. But,
and it's only Ambac that's been down
rated. But uh, yeah, you start wanting to,
reporters start calling the other
rating agencies standard and Poor's and
Moody's and others and say, are you
going to down rate these guys? And,
and you read in the newspaper
their interpretation of
what is going to be said.
And so far the other aid
agencies, I haven't, you know,
they're not saying anything,
they're not,
but now people are suspecting that
these are all going to get down rated.
Well if they're down rated then nobody
trusts him anymore as insurance companies.
Uh, and so that means that the
municipal governments will have it,
find it hard to issue bonds
to continue their activities.
So the municipal governments might have
to shut down some activities like fixing
the roads or bridges or whatever things,
building schools,
whatever the cities do with their
municipal bond money they raised from the
municipal bonds.
So then what you can see how things
are feeding through the system.
It starts out in one thing,
it goes to the insurance companies and
then it goes to the municipal governments
and all that kind of thing can,
might,
might put this economy into a recession
if it's not just the municipal
governments,
but a lot of different of
a lot of different aspects
of our financial system are
going to be touched by a crisis that
spreading from one segment to another.
Uh, so, uh, that's where this
stands right now. The latest thing.
Well, now this is a crisis.
Uh, I'm municipal bond crisis,
which is unfolding.
The New York state regulators have been
trying to get companies to subscribe
more capital to the line insurance
companies to bolster their, uh,
their capital so that they have more
money to pay out and that will prevent any
more Lorings of their
ratings. And, uh, uh,
so, uh, uh,
the other thing has happened now is that
Warren Buffet said he wants to get into
the, um, uh, municipal
bond ensuring business.
And so, well, he's just a
business person coming in. Uh,
and so there will be new municipal bond
insurers appearing that will take up the
slack.
And so we'll be all right.
But the problem is that we
may have a crisis for a while.
The other thing that I wanted to talk
about, I guess I'm running out of time,
was about, uh, uh, management
of disaster risk. Uh, and, uh,
we, we have another insurance crisis
developing now, uh, because of,
uh,
well a very important source of
insurance risk that's developing.
It has to do with the rising rate of
hurricane damage that we're observing in
the east coast of the United States.
And notably, we saw Hurricane Katrina,
uh, that caused a huge
property damage, uh,
in, uh, uh, uh, a couple
of years ago that, uh,
I kind of tested
insurance companies again.
And the risk is that global
warming will, uh, will,
uh, make hurricanes more
common. And, uh, I guess I,
I'll have to, I'll just
conclude that, uh, uh,
I'll talk a little bit about that. I've
gotten through almost all of us, uh,
next time. The only other thing, uh,
then next year we're going to talk,
on Friday we're meeting again and
we're meeting again about, um,
this time, it, it's about
efficient markets. Uh, and, uh,
I want to talk about the evidence
for efficient markets and against it.
And that will lead you into your third
problem set, uh, about efficient markets.
But that's not coming for a little while.